>>> GAME OF THRONES, IT'S MY
FAVORITE SHOW.
HOUSES, LOTS OF WINE, A BIG ASS
WALL, NEVER MISS AN EPISODE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW YOU LIKE GAME
OF THRONES.
>> I DON'T REALLY LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT MY PERSONAL LIFE.
I DON'T LIKE THAT ATTENTION.
>> OKAY.
NEVER MISS AN EPISODE, I ASSUME
SOME CROWS.
>> PETE, THIS IS MY FRIEND GRAY
WORM.
>> OH, HEY, WHAT'S UP, MAN?
>> DID YOU SAY YOUR LAST NAME IS
WORM?
>> YOU KNOW NOTHING, PETE
DAVIDSON.
>> I'M A PENIS.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO A RAP
ABOUT GAME OF THRONES JUST
BECAUSE IT'S THE MOST POPULAR
SHOW IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING, IF I'M
GOING TO DO AN EPIC RAP SONG FOR
THE FINALE, IT SHOULD BE ABOUT A
TV SHOW I LIKE?
>> I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD DO A
RAP AT ALL.
>> MY FAVORITE TV SHOW IS GRACIE
AND FRANKIE.
>> WHY?
>> ONE OF THE FIRST ONES TO BE
OFF OF FIVE SEASONS, SWEET OLD
LADIES IS THE REASON.
YOU BETTER GRAB A HANKY, THAT'S
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> GRACE AND FRANKY.
DJ KHALED.
WE THE BEST.
BETTER THAN GAME OF THRONES.
>> LET ME CATCH YOU UP A LITTLE
BIT ON THE SMASH HIT, THE
OPTIONS, AIN'T THAT CLASSIC.
>> THIS IS GETTING EXPENSIVE.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
MISSING, CRAIG T. NELSON, ERNIE
HUDSON.
THEY'RE BOTH LIKE 80 SOMETHING,
RIDING HOT AIR BALLOONS LIKE
IT'S NOTHING.
IT SURE IS SOMETHING.
>> GRACE AND FRANKIE.
THEY'RE DIFFERENT BUT THEY'RE
FRIENDS.
IT'S A NICE SHOW.
DJ KHALED.
>> I CHANGED IT.
NOW YOU JUST RAP ABOUT WHATEVER
YOUR FAVORITE TV SHOW IS.
>> ANY SHOW I WANT?
MY FAVORITE TV SHOW IS MOTHER
[ BLEEP ] GRACE AND FRANKIE.
SEASON 4 IS GUEST STARRING LISA
KUDROW.
TWO GRACES ARE UNUSUAL.
THINGS STARTING CRACKING, GRACE
HAD THAT SCOOTER ACCIDENT.
THAT'S THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
>> GRACE AND FRANKIE.
REMEMBER, WHEN HE HAD THAT SLEEP
APNEA?
THAT WAS CRAZY.
>> FRANKIE WAS SICK AND GRACE
MIGHT [ BLEEP ] MARY NICK.
GRACE AND FRANKIE, BEST IN THE
GAME.
DJ KHALED.
REACT.
>> I GOT A DRAGON YOU CAN SIT ON
RIGHT HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.